I'm experiencing pain in my spine at the location where I had surgery.
Could this be part of the healing process or a side of the disease?
The answer is yes, could be either.
The only way to only know if it's metastasized to that area is a PET scan,
or a CT scan would see that too.
It's, but it can be healing too.
So as you're healing from an injury, you're going to have pain.
So I know we said this before, whatever we have cancer,
any pain or any symptom, we go, oh, it's getting worse.
But that may be true, but it's not always true.
So we just got to be careful not to go there mentally.
The only way to know for sure is to do a scan to see what's going on.
So if the pain is excruciated and it's, you know,
that's another way to know if that, if the pain is unbearable,
it's very high at a scale of 1 to 10, that's not normal.
Is that normal, a healing pain?
Then I would definitely talk to the doctor about that.